Rocky's in Greenville South Carolina
Merry Christmas Rocky
Merry Christmas how you doing this
afternoon better than I deserve what's
up well my wife and I have just started
Financial Peace University and we're in
the first week of course and the biggest
issue that we've been having is I am
self-employed and I'm trying to figure
out how to get the budget working with
my income can be different most a month
exam yeah well there's two things you do
one is jump on every dollar calm and
start using the free online budgeting
tool and it allows you to adjust
throughout the month as your information
comes to you on what income you're going
to be able to pull out of your business
and take home right okay and so because
it does vary the second thing you can do
is is the old paper way and in the back
of your Financial Peace University
workbook is the budget forms form
I believe it's number six if I recall
there's a form in there called the
irregular income planning sheet and what
it teaches you to do is this you take
your lowest average month what would be
your low average month although would
probably be 2500 years okay take 2500 to
a regular budget with that meaning just
give 2500 a name right every dollar of
the 2500 a name you take care of food
lights probably pay the house payment of
that and you're cooking along with
whatever you can do on 2500 then there's
a list of things that didn't make the
cut in the twenty five hundred dollar
budget you follow me correct
look at that list is what this irregular
income she teaches you to do and says
this is our Sharon and I live for years
because we had a very irregular income
you look at that list and you say of the
things that didn't make the twenty five
hundred dollar cut this month what is
the most important thing if I make
twenty six hundred what's that extra
hundred going to go to what's the number
one thing on this list and you you and
your spouse look at that together and
put it one beside that once then you say
then once that thing is completely taken
care of regardless of the amount then
what is the next most
important thing and you put a - inside
that and what's the next most important
thing you put three beside that and so
on and then you rewrite the list in
order of one through whatever and really
that list should be longer than you've
ever made in a month okay because it
would like blow down into your debt
snowball it would blow down into
finishing off your emergency fund if you
got that the death snowball and so like
if you had a record month times five
then you would just you'd still have a
list you but in other words that list
should be so long that you would never
get through it right right and so as the
money comes in above twenty five hundred
you know what you do you got your
marching orders that you already decided
before the money gets there where it's
going to go because what ends up
happening with those of us that are
self-employed if you've been
self-employed long or if you're in sales
and straight commission you have a
tendency to have a little celebration
off to the side somewhere if you're
having a good month rather than stay
rather than staying on the same thing
because we have this idea that we can
out earn our stupidity yeah that's kind
of where I've always been up we I
recently bought a boat back in May and
that was my whole philosophy logic so
make some more money yeah and yeah I
tried I tried out on it for years but
stupid kept a con me from behind so I
had to get on a plan yeah I'm over being
stupid so we're we're ready to kind of
jump on this thing and that have any dad
I'm over dead we cool have y'all got you
have y'all got your tickets to the
Greenville event that Chris Hogan and I
are doing the smart money event in March
not yet it's actually in Spartanburg I
noticed that is that this farmer toriel
yeah but it's labeled as Greenville well
bring Barbour gets twin city sir
I mean we're going to definitely get
ticket that we're going to get one for
my mother as well go well yeah okay I'll
give you three for Christmas okay
awesome I appreciate it thank you you
hold on I'll have Kelly pick up merry
Christmas to you we appreciate you
calling in hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
Oh
[Music]